dans l'angle sombre d'un salon
silencieuse couverte de poussière
sans doute oublié par son maître
on apercevait l'art combien de notes
dormait dans ses cordes comme un oiseau
d'or dans les branches en attendant la
main de neige qui s'est l'arraché j'ai
pensé combien de fois le génie d'or
ainsi au fond de l'âme et attend qu'une
voix comme celle de lazard 10 lève toi
et marche
ce poème ma grand mère me l'arrêt cité
pendant toute mon enfance
à l'époque je ne savais même pas ce
qu'était une heure l'art c'est un des
instruments les plus anciens de la
création c'est un arc un arc qui va se
métamorphoser et sous différentes formes
différentes fonctions il va accompagner
l'homme sur chaque continent et au fil
des siècles c'est la muse des poètes
c'est l'instrument des troubadours c'est
un instrument noble au début du 19e
siècle les jeunes anglaises le préfère à
l'épinette parce qu'il met mieux en
valeur leur teint et leurs visages
pendant la révolution française on les
brûle c'est un instrument sacré dans la
grèce antique en egypte il sert de lien
entre la terre et l'eau de là c'est un
instrument populaire dans les pays
celtes en amérique du sud en afrique
je n'ai absolument aucun souvenir des
raisons pour lesquelles j'ai choisi de
jouer de la harpe mais c'était une
évidence
peut-être parce qu'on se ressemble notre
histoire se ressemblent beaucoup
celle d'une petite flamme très fragile
qui se bat pour ne pas mourir
celle d'un jeune soldat qui quitte
l'alsace pour rejoindre napoléon île
déserte à minsk
cent ans plus tard sonia sa descendante
quitte la lituanie car elle a décidé
d'aller travailler
elle rejoint la palestine pour cultiver
le riz la balle rencontre boris un russe
qui a fui les pogroms hors mariage ils
ont deux enfants et regagne la lituanie
le père de sonia est très mécontent il a
un gendre qui n'a pas de papiers qui n'a
pas de l'argent qui n'a même pas de nom
il faut absolument s'en débarrasser
alors il va lui payer un billet de
bateau un aller simple pour la
destination de son choix
boris choisi l'uruguay parce qu'on
uruguay en cultive des oranges ce que le
père de sonia n'a pas prévu c'est que
quelques mois plus tard elle le suit
avec leurs deux petites filles
la deuxième s'appelle félicia le soir de
ses dix ans elle rencontre carlos carlos
à 14 ans
sa famille a quitté l'italie en
désaccord avec la politique de mussolini
et carlos et felicia ne se quitteront
plus jamais pas même en 1975 lorsqu'ils
n'ont le choix qu'entre la prison et
l'exil suite au coup d'état
il quitte cette terre qui était devenue
la leur avec leurs deux filles
il envoie des cv dans toute l'europe il
n'y a que deux villes qui répondent
avignon et strasbourg et le choix se
fait très vite mes grands parents sont
architectes et ils sont tombés amoureux
de la cathédrale de strasbourg lors d'un
voyage d'étudiants et puis je pense
aussi que l'alsace et l'uruguay sont
deux soeurs jumelles de terre qui ont
été ballottés entre de très nombreuses
cultures de très nombreuses
civilisations et puis l'histoire se
répète
la fille aînée de carlos et félicia à 18
ans elle s'appelle anna et joue du
violon en partant pour une académie
d'art y était elle rencontre jean jean à
une horrible chemise orange mais c'est
le seul de ce camarade à connaître la
situation politique de l'uruguay inutile
de préciser que hannah gens sont mes
parents et que quand je n'ai a
strasbourg environ 200 ans après mon
ancêtre je boucle la boucle d'un très
long périple quand j'ai choisi l'art
comme ma mère m'a dit tu as choisi un
instrument qu on ne déplace pas un
instrument très encombrant tu met fin à
la malédiction de l'exil seulement la
repre c'est un point d'ancrage peut-être
c'est un point d'ancrage qui n'en a pas
elle n'atteint sa forme définitive qu'au
19e siècle et ce qui aurait pu être une
richesse immense s'est transformée
handicap
aujourd'hui encore la rep' est associé
un instrument de salon en instruments
mineurs à la princesse aux longs cheveux
la princesse est terré dans sa tour
d'ivoire
c'est un instrument qui a peu de
répertoire avant le début du xxème
siècle un instrument du cou qui -
invités - voulue dans les festivals
l'instrument coûteux donc peu
démocratique
je me rappelle d'une phrase terrible un
jour je fais une master class avec un
réalisateur de documentaires musicaux et
après m'avoir beaucoup félicité il va
voir mes parents et leurs 10 mai mais
quel gâchis
quel gâchis comment avez vous pu vous
qui êtes musicien laissez votre enfant
faire cet instrument avec tout ce
qu'elle a à donner
l'arpp elle ne fera rien alors vu comme
ça c'est triste c'est pas engageants et
pourtant je peux dire qu'il n'y a pas de
plus belle voix au monde que celle là
parce qu'aujourd'hui tout est inventé
on a les cartes en main pour inventer
notre parcours
j'ai vraiment l'image de ce peintre
voulu donner quelques pièces de
mosaïques une mosaïque antique et vous
lui dites dessine la suite à ton image
alors c'est le travail de tous les jours
chercher du répertoire ancien parfois
qui n'est plus édité à les transcrire
des oeuvres réalisées comme ça des rêves
musicaux des pièces qu'on a rêvé de
jouer toute son enfance toute sa
jeunesse c'est qui
ne sont pas écrites pour notre
instrument ainsi on repousse les limites
nos limites aussi les limites techniques
de notre instrument on collabore avec
des compositeurs pour créer de nouvelles
façons de jouer
et puis il faut essayer de casser les
frontières
on vit une période magnifique parce que
on a accès à toutes les musiques
anciennes avec les clés pour les
interpréter mais on a aussi accès à
toutes les musiques aujourd'hui il ya
tellement de choses qui s'écrivent
tellement de choses qui se créent la
musique actuelle ça va de la chanson à
la musique sérielle la musique
électronique le rap les musiques
traditionnelles
il ya énormément de choses et je pense
qu'un interprète aujourd'hui n'a pas le
droit de passer à côté de cette richesse
ne pas le droit de ne pas être curieux
il ya aussi d'autres barrières à
franchir
c'est vrai que en tant que musicien
classique on voit de plus en plus les
salles de concerts qui se vident le
public n'est pas très jeune alors il
faut essayer d'amener la musique
ailleurs on va dans les écoles pour
faire découvrir nos instruments
on va dans les prisons dans les hôpitaux
on va dans la rue même pour jouer pour
créer de nouvelles formes de nouvelles
formes artistiques et de nouvelles
formes de transmettre la musique il n'ya
pas de plus beau cadeau quand on sort
d'une d'une présentation scolaire
parfois dans un milieu très difficile
très défavorisé que une dizaine de
petits garçons qui viennent vous voir en
disant ramdam mois plus tard je serai
harpiste parce que c'est trop cool comme
métier c'est ya pas de plus beau cadeau
que ça et puis là je parle des formes
mais aussi en tant qu'interprète c'est
vrai que si on écoute une chanson
aujourd'hui elle est écrite avec notre
langage langage qu'on parle aujourd'hui
mais les problèmes que chacun d'entre
nous peut rencontrer
c'est vrai que si on écoute une sonate
de mozart
c'est un peu plus abstrait alors c'est
le défi de chaque musicien tout en
respectant un style une histoire
d'adapter cette musique pour que chacun
aujourd'hui puissent s'identifier se
reconnaître dans cette musique je pense
que ma mère a parlé un peu vite en
parlant de point d'ancrage parce que je
ne tiens absolument pas en place mais le
point d'ancrage c'est le vrai celui qui
en chacun de nous celui qui tend moi
c'est la richesse de tout ce que j'ai
hérité de mes origines mais de mes
convictions de mes valeurs
ce que m'a légué ma famille et j'ai fait
le choix de ne pas avoir de métier fixe
denis enseigner naître y être dans un
orchestre mais de vivre seulement de mes
concerts déjà parce que je voulais
prouver que l'arpp est un instrument à
part entière
nos instruments hockey qui peut avoir sa
propre carrière mais surtout parce que
je voulais être libre libre de
construire mon parcours est de servir
mes idéaux qu'ils soient artistiques ou
humain enfin je dirais que l'art c'est
la plus grande beauté de l'art c'est que
comme la voix il n'y a aucun
intermédiaire pas d'archers pas de
touche on fabrique le son directement
avec son corps et c'est un peu ce génie
dont je parlais au début dont le poème
parle il est en chacun de nous et c'est
à chacun de nous de de le faire sortir
avec ses mains avec son coeur pour tirer
ce qui nous fait vivre
mais c'est là
kuo la fable
dgo
l'alt en ciel
au fond du jardin
leurs multiples
de longues queues
choix
david kenya d'atteindre mia d'accueil
sony et la vaisselle à dire qu'on est là
repas l'aréna kevin soit declan hill au
saloum label allemand questions
david golis
et elle a baissé daliot
ainsi joris bingo dietsch avec evento
l'ordre matériel et que faute de
manicamp dont il comme toro que c'est me
remet au corps
qu'est ce qui provoqua
l'eau c'est la vie
et
la vie
non c'est la vie